前髪 長くないですか？
ﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞﾙ…
私が 今まで使ってきた
とっておきのアイテム
ｳﾞｨｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲﾝ……
電動ドリルです
この電動ドリルも
無限の可能性を秘めていると
思うんですよ
まぁ 今までも 動画で何回も
使ってきたんですけども
この子は 本当に役に立つ
僕 思ったんですけども
この電動ドリル
何がすごいかというと
やはり
遠心力だと思いました
何度も ごめんね？
何度も 言うんですけど
本当に、ここの回転力が異常
ここから、もう～
ここまで上がりますからね
ヴィィイイイイン
ホント、動画だと
伝わらないと思うんですけど
マジで速いからね
マジ お前…
ここのだって
お前…アレだよ？
お前 だってこれ
両面テープつけたらもう…
ヴィイイイイイイイイイン…
このすごい 遠心力を使って
今回は とある事をしようと思います
ルルルルル～ル～ルル…
ルルルルルル～…
オウェッヘｯ…
ﾊﾟﾝｯ
そう…
クラッカー鳴らす時って
こう、引っ張んなきゃいけんのですよ
この紐を
この紐を引っ張ると
ﾊﾟﾝｯ
音が鳴ると
この引っ張る力
普通に人間がね こうしてても
鳴るわけないですよ
これぐらいの遠心力だと…
ちょ怖い、怖い、怖い…
鳴りそうで怖かった
流石に、人間の力だと
これぐらいの遠心力なら
クラッカーも 鳴りませんよ
でも
これを、ひょっとしたら
このクラッカーを、ひょっとしたら
この最高速度の
電動ドリルのここに
くっ付けて
回すと…
遠心力だけでクラッカーが
鳴るんじゃないかと思いまして
今回はちょっと
遠心力だけを使って
クラッカーを鳴らしてみようと思います
これ、本当に上手くいったら
クラッカー界の常識
変わりますからね
まぁ、とりあえず一回
軽く付けてみるよ
遠心力強すぎて
ふっ飛んで行くと
僕は見た
ヴィイイイイイイイイイン…
ウィィイイイイイイイイイイイイイイ………
ﾌﾞｫﾝ
ﾊﾟｺﾝｯ
まぁ…これは予測していたよ
ちょっと強めに止めてみます
これだと 多分
取れないぐらいだと思います
回します！
ヴィィイイイイイイイイイイイン……
ウィイィイイイイイイイイイイイイン……
うわぁ
ヤバイ
手が震える!!
ブルルルルｒ……
ﾊﾟｧﾝｯ!
ハァ…ハァ…ハァ…ハァ………
パァ～ン!
ﾀﾞﾒﾀﾞﾒ…威力が強すぎて
破れるから 飛んでいっちゃうんだ
これはいけますわぁ…
かなり頑丈に付けてみたんで
これは多分、いくと思います
ヴィィイイイイイイイイン……
ウィィイイイイイイイイイイイイ…
ﾊﾟﾝｯ!!
アァアアアア
ホァ…ホァ…ホァ…ホァ………
できた、できた、できたぁ！
待って、待って
え、ま、ま、ちょ…
ちょ…ちょ…おまｯ
ちょ、おまｯ…ちょ、おまｯ…
ちょ、おまｯ……
え、ちょ、おまｯ……え、ちょ、おまｯ……
ｳﾕﾝｯ、ｴｯ、ﾊｧｯ、ﾎｫ……
うわぁ…うわぁ…わぁ…
わぁぁああああｱｱｱｱｱｱ
今ので、完全に証明されました
電動ドリルの遠心力で
クラッカーを鳴らすことが
可能ということは わかりました
で、僕はこっからしたいことが
あったんすよ…
もう鳴ることは 分かったんで
クラッカーって
こう 引っ張る向きの方にしか
飛ばないじゃないですか？
回転してて
もう…
全方向です
もう"180度"(※360度)
全部にクラッカーが
飛ぶことができるんで
もう、ねぇ
皆を祝うことができます これで
もう"180度"にいる 周りの人(※360度)
皆を幸せに出来る
『全方位発射クラッカー』が
完成することができるかもしれません
電動ドリルの先っぽに
クラッカー全部付けてみましょう
～♪
フッ…フッ…フッ……
( ﾟ∀ﾟ)ｱﾊﾊ八八ﾉヽﾉヽﾉヽﾉ ＼ / ＼/ ＼
( ﾟ∀ﾟ)ｱﾊﾊァ…
こちらが
『"180度"全方位発射クラッカーマシーン』(※360度)
で、ございます
ま、こういう感じですね
全部 上手いこと
ふっ飛ばないように
上手いこと貼り付けて
全方向に向かってクラッカーが
発射するようになっております
これを射つと
僕の周り "180度"全方向に(※360度)
クラッカーが飛んでいくというわけで
多少の…
嫌がらせみたいになります
というわけで、今回の動画めでたくね
全方向クラッカーを射って
めでたく終わりましょう
以上
クラッカー界の革命児…
はじめしゃちょーでした!!
ｳﾞｨｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲｲﾝ……
きた…きた…
やばい…きた
ハッハッハ…
ちょっと待って…
もう、これですごいよ
いきますよ!!
いきます!!!!
ﾊﾟｧｧｱｱﾝ!!!!!!
うぉわァアアアア!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
………。
ﾊﾟｧｧｱｱﾝ!!……